ask yourself these two questions what do
I want to exist even if I
don't and how much of a difference do I
make to it if you got good answers to
both of those you have meaning in life
if you have only the first but not the
second you're seeking if you have
neither you're in
[Music]
[Applause]
trouble so the title's a little bit
mislead because um I wanted to really
work at trying to introduce what the
crisis is in case some of you are
unfamiliar with my work and then just at
the very end point to um how we should
try and respond to it so what is going
on there what is this meaning that we're
talking
about well it's a
metaphor okay it's something like
this there's something like the way a
sentence hangs together is coherent and
connects the world to you with the
possibility of
truth right and of course philosophers
will argue about all of that but that's
right that's the basic part of the
metaphor and then Susan Wolf wrote an
excellent book on this meaning in life
and why it matters and what she says is
first of all she makes very clear
arguments that meaning in life is not
reducible to morality which is kind of a
project that we're trying to try right
now as a culture and given a lot of the
psychological research philos
philosophical argument I predict that
will fail you can't get meaning in life
by just having a we a well organized
moral code that you follow
okay now it doesn't mean your your life
can be independent of a moral code we're
talking about reducibility we're not
talking about independence okay I just
please remember
that okay it's also not reducible to in
sort of environmental Mastery your
ability to get success in the world we
all know the tropes of people who are
amazingly successful and their life are
empty and meaningless and the movie of
the
week okay and there's and there's truth
to that the one that you might not know
that to for me is the most
scientifically interesting um is that me
meaning in life is not reducible to
subjective well-being subjective
well-being is that sense of my life is
good I'm happy with my life I'm
contented with my life right and our
culture confuses that with wealth and
wealth is only initially predictive of
subjective well-being and then it
confuses subjective well-being with
meaning in life and so we're kind of
screwed right because I can point to
prototypical instances in which meaning
in life and subjective well-being come
apart the most powerful one is have a
kid every important measure of
subjective well-being collapses when
you're having because you're in a
shipwreck you're wet all the time
there's alarm Bells going off you're
hungry you're not sleeping the person
you thought you Lov the most hates
you right you're sick all the time your
finances are reduced every time you have
a child you actually reduce your overall
longevity so why would you do it when
you ask people they do it because it
makes their lives more
meaningful meaning in life up subject to
well-being
down okay again I'm not claiming they're
completely independent I'm claiming you
can't reduce one to the other I'm going
to I've said that twice so if you missed
a tribute you're just
evil Okay so
this also think about what that is with
the child they want to be connected to
something that has a reality and an
existence and a value beyond their own
egocentric concerns if they are good
parents that's an important if but if
they are now this is all connected to
Independent lines of research with which
shouldn't be independent suffer
psychology you may have heard this is
suffering a replication crisis many of
the social sciences is by by the way
cognitive psychology the part that
overlaps with cognitive science is not
going through a replication
crisis okay because it has Rich
theoretical debate and a lot of good
experimental compet competition and it
Pur pursues synoptic integration rather
than just incentivizing
Innovation which is very problematic for
psychology right okay all that being
said that was a little bit of a rant
rant over back here okay right so she's
got a this whole other body of work
around sense of belonging which I think
is just another way of talking about
meaning in life and by the way if you
don't have a sense of belonging you're
in trouble you're in trouble financially
socioeconomically cultural psych
psycholog like you're just in trouble if
you don't have a sense of belonging like
you you're really degrading across
multiple Dimensions um so I recommend
taking a look at she's got a little tiny
thin book which is good for sort of
popular access without being stupid
right just called belonging and she
reviews some of that literature now
what's what's happening in belonging is
I would argue and I've been arguing this
year it's it's cultural amplification of
something that is continuous with
Biology um so we used to think right
that the environment shaped the organism
that's sort of a standard interpretation
of darwinian
patterns we're now coming I I would
argue and one of the best philosophers
of biology is at the University of
Toronto because everything important is
actually happening in
Toronto right um and it's so it's this
idea around Niche construction the idea
is yes the animal is being shaped by the
environment but the en the animals also
shaping the environment so you have to
actually talk about the entire dynamical
system and then what I want you to
consider I can't give you the argument
for it now so I'm just making a gestal
argument is culture is that on on
methamphetamines it's speeding this up
and accelerating it right because think
of what's Happening culture is massively
shaping you to fit this environment and
shaping this envir environment to fit
you other animals would come in here and
go what the hell is going on like look
at how artificial this is other than the
atmosphere in our naked bodies
everything else is
technology and cultural
shaping okay so belonging is when
there's been a co-shaping of organism
and environment so they fit well so they
belong
together okay that's belonging and of
course that carries into a sense of
home another way of understanding the
meaning crisis is right and we argued
this in the zombie book and I've argued
it an Awakening from the meeing crisis
my video series right is people are
experiencing cultural domicide people
have shelter but they don't feel at
home they they don't feel at home and
the one one one strategy is nism well
there's just no home to be found the
other is I'll Retreat as much as I can
and I'll find somewhere inside myself
alone the kernel of
home right so what are the four
dimensions of meaning in life just think
about these quickly uh uh purpose which
is our culture tries to identify meaning
in life with purpose purpose is only one
of four dimensions it's not the most
important is the idea of an overarching
goal coherence that's that nomological
structure things have to make sense for
you significance you have to be
connected to something that's really
real and the one that's most important
mattering connectedness this is how you
determine if you have mattering which I
think is the core of meaning in life in
fact I think the other three point to
the fourth mattering ask yourself these
two questions what do I want to exist
even if I
don't and how much of a difference do I
make to it if you got good answers to
both of those you have meaning in life
if you have only the first but not the
second you're seeking if you have
neither you're in trouble
so think about that purpose coherence
purpose is a goal coherence is it's well
formulated my my my situation my problem
is well
structured significance and mattering
I'm connected to what's really relevant
in this situation we're talking about
really good problem solving structures
really good problem
formulation but not at the level of
individual problems like like how to
give a good talk or how to deal with
your hunger we're talking about problem
solving at the metam meaning level at
that level of the world viiew that I was
talking about earlier about how the
culture is modeling to you giving you a
cognitive grammar of how you should be
modeled to fit the world and how the
world should be modeled to fit
you right and I think that level is the
level at which we need cultural modeling
of how we deal with sort of two meta
problems and these go to the sort of
here's the cultural level and then the
meta problems are sort of at the
primordiality of our cognition and we
need the two properly connected to each
other so here's the meta level telling
us about how the agent and the arena
should fit together and what are the two
meta problems well a meta problem is any
problem that you need to Sol whenever
you're solving a problem you have to
solve these two meta problems in order
to be adaptive to be a generally
intelligent being the one is I need to
anticipate the world the farther out I
can anticipate the world in fact you do
this in L the more the more intell
intelligence you will attribute to an
entity the more purely reactive it is
the less intelligent you've got the
intuitive sense which is largely correct
that the farther out you can anticipate
the better and I think the predictive
processing framework is doing a lot to
bring some clarity and hopefully some
rigor it's still being worked out to
that notion of anticipation we can
predictively prepare for the world
that's what intelligence does for you if
you can avoid the tiger it's way better
than fighting the
tiger okay the other and these two are
interlocked is something you may have
heard me talk about once or once and or
twice relevance realization which I
think is the one of the fundamental
problems you're facing it right now
there's way too much information to pay
attention
to there's way too much information in
your long-term memory and all the
possible combinations it's combinator
explosive look in a simple chess game
just number of alternative moves you can
consider making patterns of
moves just calculate that that's number
than the that's greater than the number
of atomic particles in the
universe so what you have to do it
sounds like a Zen Coen you're
intelligent By ignoring overwhelmingly
most of the information and you zero in
on the relevant information you pay a
price for that I'll come back to that
but that is the power of your adaptivity
that is the thing I've tried to figure
out throughout my whole scientific
career it's the thing that we have to
actually give AGI and by the way the
llms don't have that for themselves very
much they're relying on us in very many
ways to supply that missing relevance
realization that doesn't mean they AR
they aren't powerful by the way and I
won't get into that there's another
great talk I've got a video essay on
that if you want
okay I won't go into how I think
relevance realization
Works um you're doing it right now
though by the way you have you have two
kinds of
attention and you have task focus is I
got to try and follow this odd person
giving these making noises come out of
his face hole and somehow I'm supposed
to turn this into ideas right that's
task focus and then you have default
mode Network your mind is wandering
you're thinking about other stuff and
it's like darwinian Evolution that's
variation and most of that gets killed
off but some of it gets taken into the
sensory motor Loop that's like the EV
that's like reproduction and so you're
reproducing your sensory motor contact
and you're constantly evolving variation
and selection variation and selection
what you pay attention to that's how
relevance realization works and it gives
you an optimal grip on the world that's
why we had all those contact metaphors
optimal grip means there's no there's no
perfect way to pay attention or size
things up because it depends on what's
the task and what is relevant to
you right even even when you're looking
at an object do you need to the details
or do you need to pull back and see the
whole thing do you above beside and by
the way you never see a full object
that's only an imaginal thing you
imagine you see the whole object you
never
do
so just published a paper end of 2022
integrating those two together
predictive processing and relevance
realization so read it because it it is
the one true thing that will save your
soul Okay so the point I need for my
this talk is that relevance realization
is not called
calculation it is that you care about
this information rather than that
information that is how you are still
different from all the computational
entities they don't care about the
information they're processing they
don't care if it's true or false you do
and you can make them act to what you
care about but they don't care for
themselves okay and it is commit him
it's caring and it's commitment you are
committing your precious attention which
is limited your metabolic resources
which are limited and your time which by
the way you should remember is limited
so it's caring it's committed
connectedness so I use this word
religio r e l i g i o which is probably
the eological origin of religion because
I want to convey because it means
connectedness but it means connectedness
in this deep way of care commitment
connectedness and here's the proposal
that when we're talking about meaning in
life and belonging we're actually
talking about
religio that's what it's a metaphor for
so we've got the top level the AG and
Arena relationship and then we have the
bottom up religio and when we when it's
working they are in consonant with each
other and people aren't suffering a
meaning crisis when it's not working
they suffer a meaning crisis
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas